hi this is pressure Locker let's discuss
the staircase paradox imagine a
staircase composed of two steps that
have a horizontal distance of four and a
vertical height of three what's the
length of the staircase we can solve
this problem by breaking it down into
its horizontal distance of four and its
vertical distance of three clearly the
total length of the staircase is the sum
which is 7 now let's redraw the
staircase instead of having two steps
we'll draw it as having four steps
what's the length of the staircase now
once again we can look at the horizontal
distance of the steps and the vertical
distance of the steps and see that the
length of the staircase is still 7 in
fact even if we change the staircase to
have more steps it will always be true
that the total length of the staircase
is 7 even if it's atomically small steps
now comes the interesting point in
geometry class if you had a right
triangle with a horizontal leg 2 4 and a
vertical leg of 3 you would solve for
the diagonal by the Pythagorean theorem
and you would find that the length of
that diagonal is 5 and this is a paradox
because how can the lengths be 5 and
also 7 at the same time if you liked
this video you should check out my book
40 paradoxes and logic probability and
game theory please subscribe to my
channel I make videos on math and game
theory you can support me at patreon to
get exclusive rewards catch me on my
blog bind your decisions on Twitter at
pressure salt Locker and you can get all
of my books at Amazon